hi there
steve kaufman uh i'm gonna continue here
i got a bit of a bee in my bonnet this
morning i
sat in on a on an e teachers
conference put put on by kirsten winkler
who describes herself as a professional
education 2.0 blogger interviewer and
edupreneur she is the founder of the
e-teachers academy and she hosts the
e-teachers conference
and so today i sat in on a conference
that had dwayne cider director of
communications from rosetta stone
shiv rad gendron operations director for
languagelab.com christopher grant
senior vice president of sklipo.com
sclipo.com
and stefan stephenson founder and ceo of
mingleville
so four people who are significant
in so far as language learning on the
web is concerned
and they used a technology that was
known
as is called whiz ich wiziq.com
and so we were able to sit there and
watch a presentation
using powerpoint slides whatever and on
the side we could scribble our little
comments as the presentation went on
and of course the subject was something
like the future of the teacher
in this world of e-learning
um you know i sometimes wonder about who
has the patience to sit through one of
my
videos for up to 10 minutes
but this e-teachers conference lasted
two hours that's an awfully long time to
sit in front of your screen
i had decided i was going to do it so i
stayed there
i don't think i would go again so
the technology the format the whizzick
wi
ziq i thought it was kind of good i'm
going to look into using it myself
for perhaps seminars on how to use link
or something
but the amount of time is just simply
too long now you could argue that
i went all the way down to san diego to
sit in on conferences
some of which were much worse than the
presentations
that we had here on this screen so in
terms of use of time
this was still relatively more efficient
than going to san diego and walking
around trying to find you know
lecture halls which is probably true
which is probably true
uh insofar as the content oh and the
other thing was it was sort of
couched and presented by by kirsten and
couched in terms of
you know everything is changing which is
true and and the first presenter
who was uh no
he's not christopher grant i guess of of
sklipo
talked about all this sort of new
technology that is changing our
behaviors and all of that is true
and the whole suggestion was that uh
you know the barriers to entry in terms
of creating websites is so
small it's going to be more and more
websites
i would caution you that the cost of
putting together a website
of any substance such as link in fact is
very very high it costs a lot of money
point number one then there was a lot of
talk about
education is a right and education
should be free
and i think the term there was digital
altruism
uh you know i hear this free thing all
the time
uh i think it's really worthwhile trying
to understand what we mean here
most people don't want to work for
nothing
so if free means that the user isn't
paying
all it means is that someone else is
paying
or that the person providing the service
is doing it for free
most programmers don't work for free
most teachers like to get paid
publishers writers managers they all
like to get paid
so either you find government funding
which means
tax money so in other words that the
taxpayers money is going into this thing
whatever you're promoting
rather than going into hospital beds
roads
uh you know or or schools or whatever
so it's not free unless you're
volunteering
now many people volunteer their services
because they have another job but
anybody that's doing something as a
major activity as their
primary activity likes to be paid
because that way
they can buy food and feed their
families so
free we have a right to free someone
should give us something
i don't think so i don't think that we
have any more a right
to free education than we have a right
to free
books shoes clothes
or a trip to hawaii uh these are all
services goods or services that someone
has to produce and the people who
produce them
like to be paid also the idea that
somehow
people on the internet are altruistic i
don't buy for a minute the only
reason that so many things are are free
on the internet
is because that's what the market
dictates because people are struggling
to find ways
to make money on the internet and they
can't afford to spend
hundreds of millions of dollars
promoting their brand so they make it
available free
in the hope that people will like it and
then at some point they can figure out
some way to make money from it
and link is very much in that same
category so i don't believe in digital
altruism
what is going to happen is that the
internet is so efficient
as a means of distributing information
that the additional cost
once something has been created be it a
book or a lesson plan or learning
content or a learning system
the cost of delivering it to two people
or two million people is about the same
so what's going to happen is that the
cost of distributing
services educational services is going
to come way down
and we're going to see an explosion of
people producing educational services
web apps ipod apps and so forth
and so that the idea that the the sort
of prevailing monopoly that your local
university or school has
you have to go there and if you want to
study um you know economics you have to
study with this professor
and what's more his courses full so you
have to take this other course that
you're not even interested in
all of that's going to change you'll be
able to get whatever you want
on the internet and a lot of schools
realize this
and i again i mentioned the a c
t f l american teachers of four
languages
the university of texas at austin has
wonderful resources
that they have put up and have made
available to other people and the idea
is that
those people are in the business of
education they are paid to be in
education
by either the state of texas or private
donors or whatever it might be people
who go to the university of texas they
pay money but they are looking for ways
and they realize that if they put up
content they share with others they can
also share
back from some of the content that
others have put up
so there is going to be a lot more
sharing
and the inner university of texas even
had a program whereby they
prepare courses but they don't print the
textbook and if you want it you print it
on demand
and it's significantly cheaper so
there's all kinds of ways practical ways
that the internet is going to make
education cheaper but there's no
right to education and there is no right
to free education
and there is no digital altruism in my
opinion
that's not to say that we don't have a
you know an altruistic impulse here and
there
which i think comes from the desire that
if we help someone else out they'll help
also so it's still a mutual altruism
uh type of thing uh i am going to do a
separate video where i'm going to talk
about the substance of these four
presentations
in particular the presentation from
dwayne
cider of rosetta stone and i want to
talk about the sort of what i see as the
two
sort of positions on language learning
there's two main positions
which is one our position at link which
is
content words get the words get the
language
in you before you can start to
understand the structure
and the other perspective which is
that of rosetta stone which is that of
grammar teachers and that is that first
we give you the structure
then you can go out and accumulate words
so that will be the subject
of my next video thank you very much for
listening